Hi.
I'm Matt Gaunt, a Developer
Advocate here at Google.
We can all agree mobile
is becoming more important
and touch screens
are a common feature.
So how can you implement
touch in your web app?
For me touch support breaks
down into these two key areas.
First, you have
the most basic way
of responding to a user's
touch by adding styles
for states, with the active
and focus pseudo-class.
Second, you have touch events
to implement your own gestures.
Let's start with the
active and focus state.
Whenever you're
designing your site,
you need to be thinking about
the styling for the default,
active, and focus
states of your elements.
Changing your UI
with these styles
stops the user from questioning
if their touch has actually
been acknowledged or not and
reduces the perceived latency
of your web app.
It makes your site feel
snappy and responsive.
By default, most
browsers will add
some kind of
highlighting to elements.
On the left is a slim orange
focus ring added to a button.
And on the right, you can
see a blue tap highlight
on an anchor tag.
Now, personally, I
hate it when my UI
is altered with some
random styling that
doesn't fit in with my design.
By adding an active
and focus style,
you get a much higher level
of polish for your site.
That's the most
basic touch response.
What if you wanted to
implement a custom gesture?
That's where we start
to use touch events.
If you've never played
with touch events before,
you need to register listeners
for touchstart, touchmove,
touchend, and
touchcancel events.
And these events will
fire throughout the life
cycle of a gesture.
You'll see one
touchstart event followed
by one or more touchmove and a
final touchend or touchcancel
event at the end.
The way you use this
is super simple.
Just get your element as
usual with query selector
or getElement by ID.
Add your event listeners with
the event name and a callback
function.
And from this you can
use the event object,
which is passed
into the callback
to get the x- and
y-coordinates out and then
react to the gesture.
Now this is the rough outline
of how everything fits together.
But there are a few best
practices you need to follow,
otherwise you can really
hurt your frames per second.
The best practices
we're going to cover
are binding low
and binding late.
Do as little as possible inside
of the touch callbacks, which
is always a good thing.
And use requestAnimateFrames.
So let's start with
bind low and bind late.
What bind low means is that
you should bind your event
listeners to the element
you want the users
to touch rather than
the entire document.
The reason for this is
that it helps the browser's
performance, since
the browser will only
hop on to the main thread
and execute JavaScript when
a touch falls in an
element with a listener,
so the one you care about.
Otherwise if you add the touch
event listeners to the document
body, we're always going
to execute JavaScript
on the main thread, even
though the touch may occur
on an element we just
simply don't care about.
So binding low means binding
to the element itself.
Binding late is
referring to binding
the touchmove, touchend,
and touchcancel
event to the element
as late as possible.
So in this example,
we want all touch
events to be handled
by our swipeable boxes
or swipe me areas when
the touchstart happens
inside one of them.
For this we add our
touchmove, touchend,
and touchcancel events to the
entire document body inside
of our touchstart
event callback.
Then when we receive a
touchend or touchcancel,
event we remove all of the
events from the document body.
So we're binding as
late as possible.
You should check out the Show
Potential Scroll Bottlenecks
feature inside of
Chrome DevTools, which
is really helpful to ensure your
logic is working as intended
and helps highlight
any potential problems.
You can find it under the
rendering tab which comes up
when you hit the
hamburger menu icon.
That's bind low and bind late.
The next thing you
need to remember
is to do as little as possible
inside the touch callback.
Why?
I hear you ask.
Because a callback is going to
be running on the main thread.
So if you do lots
of work inside of it
you can really hurt your site's
frame rate, which nobody wants.
So always try to be as quick as
possible inside the callback.
But this raises the question
of, if I get the touch's x-
and y-coordinates
inside the event,
how can I do anything
with those values
without blocking
the main thread?
And that's where
requestAnimationFrame comes in.
requestAnimationFrame is a
technique of batching changes
you want to make to
the UI at a time that
works with the browser
rather than against it.
You would call
requestAnimationFrame
and pass in a function which
basically asks the browser
to execute that function
at a suitable point
in its render [INAUDIBLE].
When the animation frame
call back is executed
you can update the UI based
on the last known touch event.
So the overall flow is you
request an animation frame,
you wait while
touchmove events fire,
and then when the browser's
ready it will call your method
and you can alter the UI.
The important thing with
this is that rather than
change the element styles
for every touch move, where
you might see multiple events
fire between render frames,
you make changes based
on the last known touch
move, which is really the only
important bit of work that
needs to happen.
So there we have it.
Touch on the web--
the most basic way
to respond to a user's
touch with the active
and focus pseudo-class.
And if you want your own
gestures use touch events.
Check out the web fundamentals
URL here for best practices,
details on cross
browser implementation--
so things like pointer
events-- and samples
where you can steal some code.
Cheers.